c a statically typed procedural
programming language famous for making
the world go around it's the language
behind many tools we take for granted
like the windows linux and mac operating
system kernels databases like mysql
interpreters for languages like python
tools like vim and git and countless
others it was created in 1972 by dennis
ritchie at bell labs where it would be
used to develop the unix operating
system it would go on to become the
mother of all languages inspiring the
syntax of c plus c sharp java javascript
perl and php just to name a few it
compiles directly to machine code and
requires minimal runtime support but is
platform dependent meaning the
executable is designed to run on a
specific operating system it's a high
high-level language designed for humans
yet provides low-level control over
memory and hardware there's no garbage
collector instead your code needs to
manage its own memory when you create a
variable it's assigned an address in
memory you can store that address in
another variable called a pointer when
the variable is no longer needed you'll
need to free it to avoid memory leaks to
get started install ac compiler a
popular choice is the gnu c compiler or
gcc create a file ending in dot c
include any libraries you plan to use
then add a main function to it this is
where your program will start executing
there's no function keyword and notice
how it returns an integer type a return
value of 0 means success while a return
value of 1 means failure there are only
a few basic types in c create a variable
by starting with a type followed by a
name and value use printf to print the
value to the standard output or put an
ampersand in front of it to reference
its address in memory there's no string
type but instead char which represents a
one byte character stored as an integer
a string can be created with an array of
characters each letter will have its own
memory address and be terminated by a
null character another approach is to
start with a pointer by adding a star
character in front of the type then we
can allocate 4 bytes to it now assign a
character to each index ending with the
null character to create a string when
you no longer need that memory allocated
to your program use free to release it
back to the computer's ram the language
is procedural and does not support
object oriented features although you
can create your own complex data types
using structs now compile your code to
machine instructions for your operating
system using the c compiler this has
been the c programming language in 100
seconds hit the like button and
subscribe if you want to see more short
videos like this thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one